[Music]
I'll show you how to deploy your Python
model into production and actually
convert you from a dead scientist into a
data engineer I don't know how many data
scientists are here can we have a rise
advanced data engineers after this talk
I guess there's no difference or that's
a good company I guess so basically my
intro is developing a model is actually
half the battle right you still need to
put it in production but apparently it's
like an overlooked battle because I have
this chart here I even made them into
Lok Lak access so a lot of people are
searching for dead scientists a lot of
people are searching for machine
learning nobody's searching for
prediction izing any of those it doesn't
happen like 13,000 hits but I think it's
an alpha Luke battle because I like in
previous presentation you only see the
benefits of a model once it's deployed
in production
shall we doubt it it's only just an
exercise so a little bit about me I have
a PC in parallel computing from TU delft
I'm a date hacker at GDD which is like
in-between yeah but basically I drink a
lot of coffee while waiting for this
pond dog thing to compute I don't know
why why you guys find this interesting I
certainly don't but apparently this
thing for dead scientists so a little
bit about my employer got it the driven
also sponsor of this conference report
of the CBI group about dead scientist
and if you buy some of us you should buy
six apparently according to oven same
applies for Givi so let's start so
basically I did this project of a client
and I'm gonna describe the process we
deployed there and the process is like
this it's a lot of steps it's quite
complicated but I'll mention all of
those in the next few slides but before
we continue any questions up to now
one question yes okay so there's a data
scientist in the back who builds models
shoot milk go into production may okay
I'll come back to that at the end of the
presentation I think it's a valid point
there is quite a gap between dead
scientist and data engineers and
depending on scale I think it might not
be the best choice to put a data science
model written by data scientist into
production but it depends on scale okay
but I'll come back to that in the end of
the first stage one more question
slide one more even oh is the DES
spelling mistake oh it's a spelling
mistake okay okay maybe it's not that
bad okay the Google shooters out the
corrected it bet their designs okay so
good laugh one of the one of our core
components just wear your house your
code right apparently to get a good lab
now those a unifies issues code reviews
see ICD into a single UI but back back
when we did the project it didn't do the
CI in the CD so give me some flak
because he used Jenkins as well for the
CICP
so what we did in our project is we had
a separate repository for each model so
it's project or is the Desai's model
headed separate yeah repository and then
when we have feature branches so if a
new improvement needed to be done on the
model you would create a feature branch
that scientists would implement the
feature to some unit testing maybe even
hardly ever happen did it happen and
when the feature was ready it will be
merged into master
and our aim of this project was that
once it was merged into master we would
actually get an automatic deployment to
death
maybe not production let's stop it death
so we use Jenkins as well so Jenkins is
like okay it's a big line but more
importantly since Jenkins - you have
this thing called pipelines as cut and
this basically means that you have a
file describing how the CIC be part of
your deployment will happen does
everybody know what CID is by the way
elaborate ok maybe I should elaborate ok
see is continuous integration so it's
like building a new version packaging it
with all the dependencies making it
ready for CD continuous deployment sorry
once you make a small change to your
model to automatically be deployed to
production CI packaging it CD deploying
it yes ok so I guess the file depends on
your definition of continuous continuous
could be like if you do really small
feature increments you could deploy
multiple times a day if you deploy more
than I know X you got continuous instead
of like every release very good answer
ok so this is another good question you
don't know how good is your feature I
think that ok it's it should maybe be
part of your deployment pipeline or CI
pipeline to test if it doesn't like
radically change the behavior of your
model but it's also something you should
do after like in the monitoring of your
model like does the city or drop like
crazy okay maybe you should roll back
it's more monitoring I think than the CI
so for Jenkins we create a separate
pipeline for each model so remember the
pipeline States which steps should be in
taken to integrate an employee I think
is actually monitoring the
mr. branch sorry once we merge this
feature the master branch changes we
start building a new a new painting a
new new version so every run a jingis
file specific to environment it's a bit
difficult but I'll come back to that at
the end of the presentation basically
you have different environments death
tests except in production Jing is build
changes a bit between those so this is
Jing is for example you see the
different stages you have some code in
between in an actual deployment but
basically with the different stages you
get this thing so you see the different
green blocks and the green blocks
represent that yeah everything went okay
within one of those stages so let's say
this this green block represents this
git checkout this 30-second block is the
docket prepare and this one is the
docker build and this is really nice
because you can monitor how long it
takes to do the continuous integration
so if over time you see like I know
packaging it takes a lot more time or
there's some problem there you can
actually monitor this change in the
Jenkins UI this is the different stages
everybody's still okay okay so then
docker so why do we use docker and of
like a VN the the typical Python virtual
environments so what we do is we add oka
container allows us to package all the
dependencies inside a container and a
containers like a like a lightweight
virtual machine more or less
probably the experts don't agree but
that's what I call it and the benefit of
this is that it it it packages all your
dependencies so not only the Python
dependencies but also like specific
versions of your Linux subsystem and
like everything everything is captured
in this one container so this removes
the dependency hole right if it runs
somewhere it'll run
everywhere depending on if the host is
Windows or it will run everywhere but
still in contrast to VMs it's the
lightweight so a lot of the downsides of
a VM big memory use it or look at the
containers itself being really big let's
remove that it's still quite lightweight
in docker so what we need to do for our
project is grace a double file for each
model in this docker file we make sure
that we run some unit tests to make sure
that we don't build a broken container
so you build your container you're in
some new tests and then if the unit
tests don't pass we spoke building the
container and what we did is we
installed mini Kumba's and dependency
saya and then the test so a really small
example of a docker file snippet okay so
what we do here we have this environment
Yama file it's like a normal Ana khumba
if I'm a dependency that dependency file
and what we did is we have a single step
a single Booker step which first
installs all kinds of dependencies
installs mini khumba installs the
environment cleans a lot of installation
like PI C files PI o files which are not
really needed then removes all the GCC
and all the stuff in one go and why do
we do this so docker has this concept of
layers so document is like an onion and
you have a core layer and then one
outside and so this means that you can
only add stuff if I would split this
operation into separate upper run
operations the the actual size would
only increase like this this cleaning I
do here it would never help because
basically it's a command like ok and now
remove this stuff but the stuff is also
actually still there because it's in a
layer between Louis
yeah so you can only add stuff so
basically it would add one layer stating
remove this and there's techniques you
could squash the final buccal container
so basically squashing all the layers
into one but the problem with the
squashing is that you can't reuse layers
between containers so that's also a bad
practice let's say so that's why you get
this these crazy code blows in a typical
poker file okay so now we have our dough
container let me know how to build those
so then why why did we choose
communities could be 90s as an output
source yeah basically container manager
in kubernetes you have multiple worker
nodes some multiple machines and on
those machines we're gonna run
containers maybe and we're gonna run
multiple containers per machine
depending on the size or how the load
etc and the nice thing of kubernetes is
that it actually manages this process so
if we're in a big project and we're
doing micro services now everybody's
doing micro services you can just throw
all these containers to communities and
it will make sure that the load is
nicely distributed amongst all those
working outs it will monitor all those
different containers if one breaks down
it will restart it somewhere else
a lot of the hassle is taken out for ya
a lot of the monitoring you have to do
is taken out so for communities create a
separate deployment file it's like a
descriptor telling kubernetes how to
launch a monitor this container and in
this descriptor deployment file it will
actually define how many CPUs and memory
you actually need and how to monitor its
liveliness and its readiness so those
are two important concept so life
newness basically means is the container
still life right is there still like a
reply to a certain HTTP call
if it's not keeping ID skills the
container and spawns it again somewhere
else and unless this concept of
readiness and basically readiness means
that if you reply with it 200 on that
request your model running inside this
container is actually able to serve
requests so it has an active connection
to the database I know it has loaded
finished loading the model itself so if
it isn't didn't finish the model didn't
finish loading the model like a boot up
it doesn't make any sense to kill it
already because starting it somewhere
else will not improve the situation
right you just have to wait a bit more
to concepts so even even nicer code
example here actually this template is
is much bigger in in practice but
basically this is this is snippet of
your Cuban net this example I'll work
I'll give you a general overview so you
have a model name which is defined here
you define how many replicas you want
for a particular container so in this
case we define two and then there's this
thing called rolling Abed which stays
Max and available as zero so basically
what is what this means is that if I
push a new version max and available a
zero go wait until the new version is
ready so the readiness probe says ok
before killing the old version so you
have like near instant switch over to a
new version without any downtime so then
you're going down we have a pointer to
an image which is basically the name of
the image we just created in the docker
step there's some ports defined how to
find the life in this probe and the
readiness squirrel probe that's
somewhere here I guess and then you can
actually pass some arguments like how to
connect to a database and you can
actually get some secrets like passwords
to connect to the database
you know secrets are actually managed by
cuban IDs
you know to check it them in into gate
or something like this just managed by
by Cuban IDs and then finally yeah
okay let's finally you know continue so
then finally you'll you'll specify the
limits how much memory how much CPU this
container I can take yes I guess if you
don't really care about this the
switching over as a good question
actually it's not a default setting so
by default we'll just if you deploy a
new version we'll just kill the old ones
and then you'll have downtime
okay so I'll repeat it for everybody
else if you have much more replicas it
might make sense we have like Mexican
available is like 10 if you your
replicas is like 20 or 5'4 and if you
have a minimum amount or make small
amount it's gonna be available while
deploying a new version so the final
step we have to do its monitoring so we
installed hipster to monitor containers
so they though if they will actually
monitor the execution nodes themselves
so we have these execution and nodes in
in communities these have CPUs in memory
as well so we monitor their CPU usage
using hipster and finally we use elk to
collect the logs of each container and
so we have the that's the the nice thing
of microservices you deploy your
container somewhere you have no clue
where you still need access to the logs
so you need to be able to you need to
set up something which is collecting
those logs from your containers pushing
in something somewhere sir centralized
to be able to actually do debugging
still because debugging sometimes is
actually quite a nice feature to have
I mean no this is JVM stick treasures
but still and then from the out stack we
actually use Cabana to create some
dashboards like how many requests your
model is doing the run time yeah how
many errors it encountered that sort of
stuff
okay so summarizing as a data scientist
in order to become a data engineer you
need to do this create the killer
project contains project what was in
your files
took a file multiple communities
deployments files some HTTP endpoints
that need to log in the correct format
should be something any that size can do
right so like building model and it's
not science executing those steps so
what we actually did is we created a
library slash framework and this this
library basically did all of that for
the dead scientist so what we did is we
like that the core essence of it was
generating most of those templates so do
you need more memory you need more CPU
all right some of the models they're
just really simple you don't need more
than one CPU if it was a bit more
complex then Mary you just specify two
or four I don't know something like this
same goes with memory right
not all PI and not all that size models
will actually consume a lot of memory
some will you could fill it in here and
then what we did
besides that is like Jeff create custom
flask at flask is a HTTP server I think
most of you are familiar with it and is
the this would allow you to expose this
data science model over HTTP calls rest
calls and it works from the premise that
your model method would create create a
or get a data frame in and it should
return a data frame everybody now
follows that frame
I hope ok so that that's basically the
coma formal
so within the predict function you could
do whatever you would like but as long
as the output was a data frame our floss
cap also had predefined health endpoints
so I could always on the life in this
profit would always return everything is
okay and on the readiness probe it would
return okay if basically the in it was
passed so if you actually started ready
still here like so so additionally okay
the custom JSON logger so basically it's
an extension of the logging framework to
make it log in JSON format actually it
turns out the JSON logging in the
console was completely unreadable but
elke our walking capturing tool which
could actually parse it really easily
just is JSON some standards where so
this JSON longer allows us to capture
the and parse basically the the log the
logs in elastic really easily then we
had a shared docker file and in this
docker file we install the base
dependencies like dominoes psych it then
by some other like a like a default by
data stack let's call it death and we
implement some connectors to databases
and a messy bit and basically this was
because okay we used Cassandra and some
there are Python connectors to it you
have to be careful let's say so by us
implementing those connectors the data
engineers would take take away it is
this careful part from the dead
scientist so everybody was happy so then
the resulting workflow say we fit the
model as a dead scientist write a small
wrapper to make it compatible with our
flask API thing create a requirements
txt file if you needed more dependencies
than the default appendices we install
already
then you run this wizard to generate all
the template files like the communities
Jenkins
everything you push it to get lap get
lap would automatically pick up like hey
I have this new repository with with
jenga's file in there and it will
automatically deploy to death
second time bit less work to do you
Maurice official feature in the master
Jenkins would pick it up and you wait
basically any question up to now still
must be really clear presentation so so
after emerge the master we use D tab so
basically you have four separate
environments death test except a
production and we would automatically
deploy to death alright that is the is
the environment which may break no
problems there everybody still more or
less happy if you break death once
everybody so the head was happy with a
particular death container or a def
release we would have ready to test
everywhere that was a more stable
environment still integration test with
all the different components wherever
done and then after test came except in
production so basically the nice thing
of this the skew varieties is that we
build the container for death and once
we think at least that a container is
stable enough to be upgraded to test it
is picked the same container and you
push it to test so there's no change if
you don't rebuild it you don't there's
nothing there everything else like
connecting to a different database or
connecting to and using a different and
loading the model home somewhere else
that's all done through configuration
parameters passed through kubernetes
basically so it's really nice from
talker
okay so this your rice okay so this was
we build a container after pushing to
merging to master yeah we did I think
okay what was a choice I made but in
theory you could build containers while
pushing to any branch right but then I
think the problem with building all time
is for any branch is that it becomes a
bit unclear which version is now
deployed to death right because if you
commit something to a branch it would be
pushed to death and if you're working
with two people one project you have two
branches and like the last one wins so
nobody knows anymore rich version is
deployed now we also had like small
bests boards which stated which version
was deploy above Wow so that could help
but in the end for simplicity reasons I
chose to only deploy master welcome back
to that yeah sure Booker tags have to be
a bit careful about that because the
problem with docker tags or reusing
docker yeah pocket tags is that you
can't really know anymore which version
is deployed because if you have multiple
repositories as my container synced from
one repository to the other or not so if
I check out master and it's a different
repository you don't really know if I'm
checking out the last master that one
before
a cabin and then you don't really see ya
you could prepended okay then in the end
I think it still boils down to the -
more or less the same problem I said it
was a personal choice for me to deploy
master this one is one which could be
debatable okay again I think there's
some debate around how you would deploy
I think multiple branches could could be
okay that at the time I was I chose to
only deploy master
so then is it more or less the same
image as I started with but now with the
different deployment right and the
docker registry so we start with the
coding gitlab Jenkins does the check out
and builds the container the result of
the Jenkins build is a docker container
which is pushed to the docker registry
and then we have separate jenga's jobs
which fire to deploy a version to the
different detail environment so this dev
test except in production because it's
about this yeah
okay so okay so in this project we had
two week cycle that's a release cycle
just print and then how long would it
take from gitlab to production I depends
right on the on the Thursday before
going to production and this would be
one day or half an hour yeah but yeah if
it's the first community do it takes two
weeks now there's nothing keeping you
from doing it continuously that's does a
good point
if in essence what we did is we had one
Jenkins job doing this part yeah
checking out codes pushing to the docker
registry and then we automatically fire
the DEF deployment you could fire more
you could also say okay I don't need
tests and except let's do the death
works
boost production that's how you want to
organize your whole team let's say it
ties into my almost lost light which is
less learned so I think automatically
appointment to death is a really nice
thing also depending on your team also
but I think some oversight still
so in the end it's still depending on
this it's still something to scientist
it more oversight than others which
makes sense right but he started with a
different education I know that
scientists come from a analytical
background I learned a lot about
statistics I know less about statistics
a bit more about programming
so without the oversize it sometimes
leads to somewhat Messier repositories
it doesn't have to be necessarily the
case but it is something you need to
take into account and especially if you
optimize everything away like this it's
really easy for for any basic anybody to
do a deployment to production because
all the yeah it's just streamlined then
again I think investing in the framework
and our library paid out big time we had
a more uniform code base and they do fly
me in that firm out there was this video
API we have and also new features in the
framework would improve all the dead
science models so instead of having to
fix a certain problem at I don't know 10
different dead science models you just
fix it in framework apply to pointers to
all the data science models and then
done that really helped a lot
and then the final remark it is more or
less like one of the earliest questions
we have here how you still need to
monitor the performance of your models
so what we did is we had some like
regression tests for each model they
have like a baseline performance but if
the performance degradation is more
subtle like the click-through rate
degrades only a couple percent this unit
test was not designed to capture that so
you still need to think about how am I
gonna monitor your model once it's being
deployed to production and there's still
a big thing there and there's no capture
this is talk okay so that's it
any questions
[Music]
[Applause]